Patrick is with us in Seattle
hey Patrick welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave thanks for taking me sure
how can I help
well I'm on baby supplies with my wife
we did it about three months ago though
and we've just stagnated facilities and
credit cards just bought a new car and
the thing is we're not really I finally
convinced myself that it's time to cut
the credit cards and really get rid of
this debt and I need to convince my wife
of it but she's I haven't even tried yet
my question is you know she wants to go
to Costco today to buy groceries on the
credit card do I put my foot down or do
I let her you know do I slowly convince
her within the week or do I put my foot
down and say no we've got to stop you
have money or not yeah we've got four
thousand dollars in bank account why
don't you turn a Costco
she likes the perks that the cards give
you know that bonuses that they give out
and the miles and stuff like that so
what kind of stupid car did you buy
Hyundai Elantra jeez we're a new yeah
yes what did you pay for that 14,000
okay yeah what's your household income
that's about 140 gross mm-hmm okay then
you're broke well we've got sixty six
thousand total debt with two cars and
credit cards sounds to me like you're
broke yeah you make a hundred forty
thousand dollars a year and you're broke
how old are you well I'm 32 and she's 31
yeah when you're broke out forth we've
got four kids and a fifth along the way
mm and you're born up I think one of our
issues Davis I'm a I'm a cop and the job
is so secure that we're not even scared
of scared of like that you know you meet
somebody when you're being a policeman
that should be scared
but isn't yeah you're broke you have
five kids you make 140 thousand dollars
a year you don't have nothing you ought
to be scared I am now I am Dave I took
me a week of reading your book and
listening to yourself but now I am and I
need to convince my wife of that too
okay so it's not a matter of putting
your foot down it's a matter of talking
through why not what the credit card at
Costco is not going to kill you one way
or the other you don't went and bought a
$14,000 car yeah how's the credit card
of Costco gonna screw this up right so
one time you know so it's not a matter
of that it's no matter if you guys need
to sit down and go okay we make a
hundred and forty thousand dollars a
year
number five is on the way we're broke
this ain't working continuing to do the
same thing over and over again and
expecting a different result is known as
insanity right yep this is the
discussion so honey I mean I don't want
to work like this and have nothing at
this rate these kids are a student loan
looking for a place to happen at this
rate our retirement is not going to be
pretty at this rate we're gonna feel
like a rat in a wheel our whole life I
don't like this I think we can do better
let's sit down and talk about what we
could do and how we might actually win
and why we need to win we have five
little birds to feed here we need to win
we need a family tree change we're
wasting a hundred and forty thousand
dollars a year with our money
philosophies our money philosophies
apparently suck this what it sounds like
right it's not about Oh wagging your
finger about you know you went to Costco
and used a credit card that's not it I
mean we need to get a umph under this
and go why in the world would anyone
keep living the way you're living and
that's the way you talk about it you
talk about why cuz honey and we make
enough money we shouldn't be broke we
make enough money our retirement should
look like millionaires we make enough
money these K will pay for these kids
college and save up and do that we make
enough money
we ought to be able to live without
financial stress and yet we live
hand-to-mouth making 140 a year this is
kind of sad don't you think baby and you
start about you to get up on it you see
what I'm doing you're getting up under
it and talking about why we need to do
this why we need to do this why we need
to do this why we need to do this and
then you worry about what we need to do
if you start working on what to do
before somebody's going along with the
why all you are is a bossy person then
okay but you make enough money to not be
broke and you're broke that's your why
agree I agree yeah I mean it's not good
you know you look good on the outside
but it's a complete fraud
totally you're broke you know and when
you start saying that out loud like that
like I've said it to you ten times in
this conversation already trying to make
sure you understand you know when you
start saying it out loud like this it
really kind of shakes you up and that's
what happened to Sharon and I we went
you know well you went broke you know
and we're looking at we're stupid we
can't be stupid anymore stupids making
us broke and we're looking at each other
going I'm gonna be stupid anymore she
goes I don't be stupid anymore and we're
not gonna do this stupid stuff anymore
and we just started talking about it out
loud because everybody walks around
acting like everything's okay
because their car payment is current and
so they say stupid but stuff like I can
afford the car you can't afford the car
because you didn't pay for it so we know
you can't afford it that's why you have
a car payment that means you couldn't
afford it that's the very definition of
couldn't afford it you are a total fraud
you're faking it I'm talking everybody
else out there now Anthony okay so I
mean Patrick so thank you for serving on
the police force sir and I appreciate
you protecting the folks in Seattle now
you guys need to sit down together join
arms not wag fingers join arms and talk
about the future and how it needs to be
different and the way it's going to be
different is we have to pay a price to
change this crap because it ain't
working or broke thanks for the call